let's take a look at the latest actions
by President Trump up cusack is
editor-in-chief of the hill Bob good
morning good morning Anthony the
president's effectively kicked the Iran
deal back to Congress so what's the
reaction to Capitol Hill on Capitol Hill
to this well Republicans are basically
saying they support the president but
the question is what will the Republican
Congress do will they move forward with
sanctions which would definitely kill
the deal will they come up with a new
deal that could be approved I think
they're gonna hold hearings and they're
not gonna get a lot done certainly over
the next 60 days because I say they've
got a budget deal and a tax reform they
don't really want to handle this issue
it's it's too hot right now
well and diplomacy between the White
House and Capitol Hill is not at an
all-time high if you look at the
tit-for-tat between Senate Foreign
Relations share bob corker and president
trump bob corker said to the washington
post that the president has in bob
corkers words castrated Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson what is your
assessment of the relationship their
relationships are very important to
Washington and bob corker is a key
member of the Budget Committee a
chairman of the Foreign Relations
Committee as you say he's gonna need a
bob corker on tax reform so this is a
problem this feud is only escalating and
remember corker corker is retiring he's
not running for reelection so he's he's
a free agent you don't think that this
is some kind of reverse psychology that
corker is trying to convince Trump to be
more engaged in the diplomatic process
it could be as much to the Washington
yeah but I've never seen Corky used this
strong language I mean he's such a
pragmatic guy and and certainly you know
Trump says he's a counter-puncher well
we we've seen Bob Walker's now a counter
puncher right meanwhile as we as we
mentioned president from also took the
major step of doing a kind of a key part
of Obamacare ending these subsidies what
is he trying to do here do you think
well number one he's trying to hollow
the Obama legacy on a number of fronts
especially health care he was very
frustrated that the Obama care bill did
not pass so he's doing I think what he
promised to do is to basically cut Obama
care the question does he get blamed who
knows but he wants to have Democrats
come to the table that hasn't worked yet
I don't think that's going to work
there's no signal the Democrats are
going to come to the table so so what is
what is he really expecting here just
because he could end up with some pretty
angry people who lose coverage yes
it's incredibly risky for the president
to do what he's doing right now because
it could backfire on him I think this is
a negotiating tactic it's something that
works with his base that well Congress
couldn't gut Obamacare so I'm going to
our Republicans on the hill happy that
he's done this no they don't like this I
mean this is something that they they
sued the House Republicans did sue the
Obama administration on these payments
saying they were not constitutionally
that Congress had to approve them now
the question is will Congress actually
step in and put it in some type of deal
what is this new for 2018 in the midterm
election a great question I think it
could hurt some swing state Republicans
and they remember in a lot of these
districts people will lose coverage and
they're gonna blame President Trump but
it depends on the PR battle can can the
bully pulpit blame President Obama and
the Democrats for crafting what they say
is a flawed law the next big hurdle here
for that for the for the Congress seems
to be the whole issue of tax reform how
ready for that are they well we haven't
seen a bill yet we were supposed to see
a bill months ago and Republicans on
Capitol Hill say just release the bill
the reason why they're not is that they
know that when you release a tax reform
bill there are winners and losers and
the lobbyists are gonna swarm and pounce
on this bill so I think it's gonna be
very difficult to get it through both
the House and the Senate Senate
especially the Senate now Republicans in
the Senate Mitch McConnell's with
meaningless centrist Democrats including
joe Manchin because remember John McCain
voted against the 2001 and 2003 tax cuts
you can't count on John McCain to
support this bill there are so many
variables one one of the biggest ones
looming in the horizon is Bob Muller's
investigation we know that former chief
of staff Ryan's previous met with him
what are we expecting on that front in
the coming weeks I mean it looks like
this thing is wrapping up I mean if he's
talking to chief of staff and it didn't
speculation that that next would be
President trumpet Muller personally
would would interview Trump I think from
a big standpoint you've got to get this
this investigation done either this year
or you pick it until the end of next
year so you don't have the investigation
during an election but there are like 17
stories discussion thank you for you
time my friends thanks Alan